if you're Beyonce  the show must go on Tizen trial on  Saturday the formation singer was on  stage for a title concert in New York  City  when her ear started bleeding mid  performance must be on soon  hey y'all food you can see be wiping  away the blood after she ripped out her  earring following some fierce dance  moves Queen Bee appeared unfazed by the  painful experience handling it like a  pro and continuing to belt out her hit  song haunted the onstage mishap seemed  to happen when yon says long braids  caught on to her earring and speaking of  show-stopping accessories the singer  slayed her pre-show look on the black  carpet sporting a gorgeous embellished  gone and arm full of bangles and the  same earrings  you